.
>> EMILY: JOINING US TODAY,
NICOLE SAPPHIRE AND RAYMOND --
WE BEGIN WITH NEW FALLOUT OVER
THE TWITTER CENSORSHIP ISSUES.
THEY JUST FIRED JAMES BACKER.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE INITIAL
CENSOR OF THE BIDEN LAPTOP
STORY.
HE HAD QUITE AN INTERESTING
RESUME BEFORE THAT INCLUDING A
STINT UNDER F.B.I. AGENT JAMES
COMEY, WHERE HE WAS A CENTRAL
FIGURE IN THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
HE TOLD CONGRESS HE PERSONALLY
REVIEWED THE PFIZER APPLICATION
THAT WAS USED TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NOW HE'S ACCUSED OF GOING BEHIND
MUSK'S BASK, DELAYING THE
RELEASE OF THE SECOND BATCH.
JOURNALIST MATT -- WHO FIRST
BROKE THE NEWS, NOW REVEALS HOW
BAKER'S ROLE WAS UNEARTH
TWEETING OVER THE WEEKEND, WHILE
WE BOTH DEALT WITH OBSTACLES TO
NEW SEARCHES IT WAS BARRY WEISS
WHO DISCOVERED THAT THE PERSON
IN CHARGE OF RELEASING THE FILES
WAS SOMEONE NAMED JIM.
WHEN SHE CALLED TO ASK JIM'S
LAST NAME, IT CAME BACK, JAMES
BAKER.
THE NEWS THAT BAKER WAS
REVIEWING TWITTER FILES
SURPRISED EVERYONE INVOLVED TO
SAY THE LEAST.
THE NEW TWITTER CHIEF ELON MUSK
ACTED QUICKLY TO EXIT BAKER ON
TUESDAY.
RAYMOND, YOU KNOW, THIS GUY IS
ESSENTIALLY THE FOREST GUMP OF
EVERY MAJOR ANTI-TRUMP ENDEAVOR
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS,
POSSIBLY PLUS, AND AS GREENWALD
WRITES IT'S A BIT DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN THE U.S. SECURITY STATE
HAD NO ROLE IN TWITTER
CENSORSHIP REGIME WHEN BAKER WAS
CENTRALLY INVOLVED IN RUSSIA
GATE AND ALL SORTS OF
POLITICIZED ABUSES AND SOMEHOW
ENDED UP AT THE DEPUTY GENERAL
COUNSEL AT TWISTER WITH HIS PAWS
IN EVERYTHING.
>> AMAZING.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO GAVE THE
OKAY FOR THOSE FAKE PFIZER
WARRANTS THAT LOOKED INTO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, SO IT'S
WORSE THAN FOREST GUMP.
HE WAS A NICE, PASSIVE BAR TAKER
IN EVERYTHING.
THIS IS A PARTISAN JACK THE
RUBBER.
THIS GUY WAS IN THE F.B.I.
THEY BRING HIM TO WORK AT
TWITTER.
THIS IS LIKE INVITING HARVEY
WEINSTEIN TO RUN THE GIRL
SCOUTS.
YOU DONT'S DO THAT.
HE HAD HIS HANDS IN THE
WEAPONIZATION AND
POLITICALIZATION OF THE F.B.I.
THEN HE MOVES TO TWITTER AND
BECOMES THE CONDUIT FOR THE
F.B.I. TO CONTROL INFORMATION
FLOW AT TWITTER WITH A PARTISAN
END.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
AND WE NEED SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS.
>> AS OF NOW IT'S BEEN INCUMBENT
UPON ELON MUSK TO DISINFECT
EVERYTHING, THROW BACK THE
CURTAINS BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE
FOLLOW THROUGH TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WHAT ABOUT THOSE OTHER
PLATFORMS.
>> HE HAS A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
TWO THINGS ABOUT THIS STORY
REALLY JUMP OUT TO ME, EMILY.
ONE OF THEM IS ELON MUSK SAID HE
DIDN'T KNOW ANY OF THIS WAS
GOING ON.
CAN HE TRUST ANYBODY?
LIKE NO ONE IS WILLING TO TELL
MUSK WHAT'S GOING ON?
HE WAS RIGHT WHEN HE SAID I'M
GOING TO CLEAN THE HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GOTTEN TO
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO LEAVE
SO HE'S GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
I'M GOING TO BORROW FROM PETE.
HE JUST SPOKE FOLLOWS ON THIS
LAST HOUR THAT GOT ME THINKING.
FACEBOOK, OTHER PLATFORMS.
WHO ARE THEIR JIM BAKERS?
ARE WE LOOKING AT A SITUATION
WHERE CAMPAIGN BY THE DEMOCRATS,
PARTICULARLY THE BIDEN FAMILY,
MIGHT HAVE HAD SOME SUPPORT WITH
CERTAIN ISSUES THAT WE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THE JIM BAKERS PLACED
ON PLATFORMS.
IS THERE MORE THAN ONE OF THIS
TYPE OF THING GOING ON?
YOU'RE RIGHT.
INVESTIGATING IT AND THE FOLLOW
THROUGH AND ALL OF THAT BUT
SOMEBODY -- ELON MUSK AND I SAID
THIS, HE CAN'T BUY EVERYTHING SO
DOES HE HAVE TO BUY THESE OTHER
PLATFORMS TO FIND OUT WHO IS
WORKING THERE?
DO WE NEED A CROWD FUND TO HELP
ELON MUSK?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT WAS MY POINT.
FOR EVERY PLATFORM, HAVING A
LIKELY JIM BAKER, NOT EVERY
PLATFORM HAS THE BENEFIT OF AN
ELON MUSK.
INTERESTINGLY AGAIN, GREENWALD
POINTED THIS OUT, NONE OF THIS
IS SURPRISING.
ZUCKERBURG TESTIFIED TO THIS.
WE'RE SEEING IT EVERY DAY.
YET ONLY LIBERAL JOURNAL I HAVES
AND THE DEMOCRATIC FUNCTIONARIES
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
>> I THINK IT'S NICE AND
REFRESHING THAT ELON MUSK HAS
COME IN, WITH MORE MONEY THAN
ANYONE IN THE WORLD, HAS COME IN
TO PULL BACK THE CURTAIN AND
UNPEEL THE ONION, WHATEVER
ANALOGY YOU WANT TO USE, TO SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
NOW WE HAVE PROOF.
LISTEN TO THIS.
THE F.B.I. LAD THE LAPTOP IN
DECEMBER 2019.
THERE ARE VIDEOS ON THERE WITH
HUNTER'S VOICE, PICTURES OF
HOOKERS, FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
WHY DID IT TAKE 10 MONTHS?
FINALLY "THE NEW YORK POST"
REPORTS IT.
THEN THEY CENSOR IT AT TWITTER.
WHY, THE F.B.I. HAD 10 MONTHS
BEFORE THE STORY CAME OUT, WHY
DIDN'T THEY GET TO THE BOTTOM?
WHY DIDN'T HE GET INTO TROUBLE?
WHAT'S SO HARD TO VERIFY ABOUT
THAT?
YOU PLAY VIDEOS, THE F.B.I. KNEW
"THE NEW YORK POST" HAD THE
STORY, GIULIANI HAD THE
INFORMATION ON THE HARD DRIVE.
THEY GO IN, MEET WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA ONCE A WEEK TO TALK TO
THEM.
>> THAT'S A LOT.
>> GUESS WHAT'S COMING?
YOU'RE GOING TO GET HACKING
INFORMATION, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
A STORY.
JUST KNOW IT'S HACKING AND IT
WILL PROBABLY INVOLVE HUNTER
BIDEN AND PROBABLY DROP IN
OCTOBER RIGHT BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY SAID
THIS IS WHAT THE FIB WAS TELLING
US ABOUT.
THIS MUST BE THE STORY.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
WHY IS THE F.B.I. INVOLVED IN
POLITICS?
THEY NEED TO BE SEPARATE ENTERS
SO WE CAN TRUST THIS
ORGANIZATION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WONDERFUL
PEOPLE THAT WORK THERE.
THE INFORMATION WAS HELD FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO BENEFIT
ONE POLITICAL PARTY.
AND IMAGINE IF THIS HAD HAPPENED
TO DONALD TRUMP.
IMAGINE IF THIS HAD HAPPENED TO
ANY REPUBLICAN?
THE STORY WOULD BE THROUGHOUT
AND ALL THE NETWORKS WOULD BE
REPORTING IT.
>> INSTEAD, IRONICALLY, COMING
AFTER THE JIM COMB ANY EGG ON
THEIR FACE EMBARRASSMENT YOU
WOULD THINK THE F.B.I. WOULD GO
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO ENSURE THEIR
REPUTATION REMAINED SACRED, THAT
THERE WAS NO QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THERE WAS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST ABOUT THEIR BEHAVIOR.
THIS JUST THROWS THAT OUT THE
WINDOW.
>> WHAT IT BRINGS UP IS A BIGGER
POINT.
WHILE THE HUNTER BIDEN CRIME AND
THE TIES WITH THE POLITICAL
PARTY, THAT CERTAINLY NEEDS TO
COME OUT.
WE NEED SOME GOOD JOURNALISM FOR
IT.
FOX NEWS IS DOING GREAT JOB.
I WISH OTHER MEDIA OUTLETS WOULD
COVER IT MORE.
>> OR AT ALL.
>> WITH BIG TECH, WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE, WITH THE F.B.I., THIS
SHOULD SHOCK ALL AMERICANS.
THIS IS FEELING A LITTLE BIT
CCP-ISH.
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA.
MINIMAL GOVERNMENT INTRUSION,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE NOW
MOLDING WHAT WE SEE, WHAT WE
HEAR, AND THEY ARE HAVING DIRECT
INFLUENCE INFLUENCE ON OUR
ELECTIONS.
>> WHAT'S CRAZY TO ME, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, THE LURKER, THE
STALKER, THAT'S EVERYWHERE, THE
AUDACITY OF BAKER TO REMAIN AT
TWITTER THROUGH ELON MUSK
ASSUMING THE CHIEF ROLE, HOW
DOES THAT COME INTO PLAY?
>> THIS IS PICKING UP ON WHAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THE F.B.I., THERE ARE BIG
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE F.B.I.
WHAT DID THEY KNOW?
WHY WERE THEY ENGAGED IN
PARTISAN ELECTION-EERING.
THEY EMBEDDED THEM IN THESE
MEDIA OPERATIONS.
REMEMBER, JIM BAKER WAS THE GUY
WHO SAID WHEN THE PFIZER
APPLICATION CAME, HE'S LIKE
DROWNING FRAT BOY WITH THREE
KIDS.
LET'S GO DO IT.
GET THOSE WARRANTS.
SUDDENLY HUNTER'S LAPTOP ARRIVES
AT TWITTER.
WE HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS, THIS
HASN'T BEEN VETTED.
WE HAVE TO CHECK IT OUT.
>> SO THE PART THAT I WANTED TO
GET OUT WAS THE COMMUNIST PARTY.
THAT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
CONNECTION, THEY ALSO HAVE A
PRETTY BIG PLATFORM CALLED TIK
TOK.
AND YOU SAW THE GOVERNOR OF
MARYLAND TODAY CUT OFF, YOU
KNOW, HE'S TRYING TO CUT THE
FAUCET OFF OF TIK TOK IN HIS
STATE.
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER PLACE WE
REALLY HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BECAUSE WHO WOULD LOVE A
SITUATION LIKE THIS.
PEOPLE COMPLICIT TO DESTROY ONE
PARTY OVER THE OTHER AND THE
CCP, THEY DON'T CARE WHICH
PARTY.
THEY JUST LIKE ALL THE CHAOS AND
THE DIVISION IN AMERICA.
>> WE'RE VERY CRITICAL OF TIK
TOK BECAUSE OF HOW THE CCP IS
INVOLVED IN THAT BUT WHAT ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH OUR OWN
TECH, TWITTER AND FACEBOOK.
THEY ARE COMPROMISED.
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW ARE YOU HANDLING THAT IN
YOUR HOUSE?
MY DAUGHTER IS SEVEN.
YOUR BOYS ARE YOUNG.
YOUR OLDER SON MIGHT HAVE TIK
TOK.
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE ON IT.
HOW DO WE HANDLE THAT?
>> I'M A HELICOPTER MOM.
SO, I PROVIDE THE DEVICE, SO I
HAVE RULES.
AND IF YOU CAN GET A JOB AND BUY
SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLAR iPHONES,
LET ME KNOW.
OTHERWISE, YOU'LL USE AN OLDER
PLATFORM, YOU KNOW, THEY DON'T
HAVE A 13 PRONG AX LIKE I DO BUT
I PUT THEM ON THE PLATFORM AND I
SAY, THE IG IS WHERE YOU CAN BE.
IT'S GOT PRIVACY CONTROLS.
THAT'S THE ONE THAT I THINK IS
FINE.
IF INSTAGRAM CHANGES I'M OFF TO
THE NEXT.
THEY HAVE TO BE ON A PLATFORM
THAT OFFERS PRIVACY, 13 AND 15.
>> WHEN YOU WERE ON FOX AND
FRIENDS --
>> LET'S CO-WRITE A BOOK.
>> I WAS ASKING YOU, GIVE ME
YOUR ADVICE BECAUSE YOUR
CHILDREN ARE GOOD AT SPORTS AND
THEY ARE DETERMINED.
>> AND BEAUTIFUL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU HAVE TO STAY ON THEM.
>> AND YOU MAKE IT, I MEAN,
COMPULSORY.
THEY KNOW THAT WHEN THEY STEP
OUT OF LINE WHAT'S THE FIRST
THING I'M COMING FOR?
THAT'S THEIR THING.
THAT'S THEIR GENERATION.
>> AND LAT